hey guys it's justine and in front of me
i have 22 watch bands representing 22
different countries they released these
in honor of the tokyo summer olympics
and i'm so excited to unbox them because
they all look so
great so let's get started
i love the gold detailing that they have
on the apple watch logo you can see it
it's reflective
oh there's even some gold detail right
here i love it it's reflective and
beautiful
check that out usa all the way look at
this
so to get the corresponding apple watch
face you just have to scan this app clip
and that'll give you the corresponding
watch face for each watch
band there's a lot of watch bands here
sport loop bands are my favorite
i do love the solo loop but there's just
something about this
it just feels so great and it's easily
adjustable unlike these ones where you
do have to know what size you want
you've got a little detail right here
with a little usa written right there on
the inside
this is nice oh i'm i'm so excited
let's scan this app clip this stripe
matches your new band
look at this here it is adding to my
faces
i love that i can change the various
styles there's a full screen
there's a circular i can change the
stripe sizes
that's pretty great one watch band down
only 21 left to go and here's our south
africa watch band
look at this
[Music]
great britain
time for italy
[Music]
and here's russia
australia
[Music]
there's still so many more to go one two
three four five six
we still have 15 left oh my god
and here's china
[Music]
and here's the netherlands
time for friends
germany
and here's grace
[Music]
mexico
this is the most exhausting thing that
i've ever done
and i'm barely doing anything oh sweden
[Music]
canada
here's brazil
[Music]
time for new zealand
south korea
[Music]
we have four more left next up we have
belgium
[Music]
okay we are officially out of room over
here so i think we're gonna have to
[Music]
do this
here's japan
[Music]
time for jamaica
and our last and final one we have
denmark
[Music]
and that is our last apple watch band
that we have to unbox here in the
country edition of the international
sport loops that apple has released
these are so cool and i'm so glad they
did this i would love to know from you
guys
where are you from what country you're
from and also what is your favorite
olympic sport is there anyone that
you're cheering for
are you actually an olympic athlete do
you have friends or family that happened
to be going to the olympics or do you
have future plans to become
maybe a potential future olympian i'd
love to hear all of those and more in
the comments below and if you guys are
new here hello welcome to my channel i
make a lot of fun tech videos you guys
hit subscribe it's free and you can also
hit the bell to be notified
when i post new videos and if you
enjoyed this video be sure to hit like
and i will see you guys in the next one
now the question is which watch band am
i gonna wear i think new zealand
might be my favorite because it is the
black and white aesthetic and i think
it's beautiful
new zealand gotcha
you